as a pot of tea cools the temperature of
the tea is modeled by a differentiable
function H for zero is less than or
equal to T is less than or equal to ten
where time T is measured in minutes and
temperature H of T is measured in
degrees Celsius values of H of T at
selected taught at selected values of
time T are shown in the table above so
that's right over there use the data in
the table to approximate the rate at
which the temperature of the tea is
changing at time T equals three point
five show the computations that lead to
your answer so they give us a bunch of
points so let's just graph this just so
we can visualize what this data is
telling us a little bit and I suspect
that this might be useful so this right
over here is our temperature axis this
is our temperature at any moment in
degrees Celsius and then this is our
time axis and they gave us the time zero
to five nine and ten or they give us a
temperature at those times so this is
zero to five is a little bit further
five nine and then 10 and at time zero
the temperature is 66 degrees Celsius 66
so it's right over there at time two it
is sixty degrees Celsius at time two it
is 60 degrees Celsius at time five it is
52 degrees Celsius so time five maybe
it's right over here this is 52 degrees
Celsius at time nine an hour after nine
minutes I should say it's at 44 degrees
Celsius so this is 44 degrees Celsius
and after 10 minutes it's at 43 degrees
Celsius so this is really just a graph
showing how it cools off over those 10
minutes over those 10 minutes that's
what the data is telling us it's kind of
a curve like this and we've sampled it
at these points so going back to Part A
use the data in the table to approximate
the rate at which the temperature of the
tea is changing at time T equals 3.5 so
the rate of change is really just the
slope of this curve at time T is equal
to 3.5 so really we just want to find
the slope at that point right over there
we want to find the slope and we don't
know the actual function so the best way
to approximate the slope at that point
is really just find the slope between
time between minute five and minute
two so the rate of change so we could
say we could say that the rate the rate
is going to be approximately our change
in temperature over that over those
three minutes so H of five minus H of
two and this is obviously going to be in
degrees Celsius over the number of
minutes that changed so we from five
minutes or from we end at five minutes
and we started at two minutes and so the
rate the rate is going to be
approximately at five minutes our
temperature is 52 degrees 52 degrees at
two minutes our temperature is 60
degrees 60 degrees and then this is over
a change in three minutes 5 minus 2 is 3
so this gets us let me scroll to the
right a little bit this gives us
negative 8 negative 8 degrees Celsius
over 3 minutes or the rate at the rate
at taught at 3 and a half minutes is
going to be approximately negative 8/3
degrees Celsius per minute so that is
Part A Part A and then Part B using
correct units explaining the meaning of
1 over 10 1 over 10 times the definite
integral from 0 to 10 of H of T DT in
the context of this problem use a
trapezoidal sum with the four
subintervals indicated by the table to
estimate this thing so the integral from
zero to 10 of H of T is really the area
of this entire under this curve right
over here that's the integral that's
this part right over here and then we're
going to divide that we're going to
divide that by we're going to divide
that by 10 so what this is really giving
us this is this expression right over
here is the average this is the average
temperature this is the average
temperature over that time period the
integral of the temperature function
divided by the total amount of
time that has that has elapsed and then
in using correct units well it's the
average temperature the average
temperature is once again going to be in
degrees degrees Celsius and it makes
sense because this right over here is in
degree Celsius you're multiplying it by
time right over here but then you could
divide by you're dividing I'm assuming
by time right over here so this is times
minutes divided by minutes so then you
just get degrees Celsius again so this
is this expression right over here is
just the average temperature over those
10 minutes then they say use a
trapezoidal sum with the four
subintervals indicated by the table to
estimate this so the trapezoidal sum is
we don't know the exact function here so
we won't be able to analytically
evaluate this definite integral but what
we can do is divide is divide this area
into four sections they tell us to use
this four subintervals
and we'll essentially divided into four
trapezoids so this is one trapezoid
right over here so this is one trapezoid
right over there that's my first
trapezoid from zero to two on the base
and you see on the left end of that
trapezoid is high 266 the right end is
60 and then the next trapezoid will go
from 2 to 5 let me do that in a more a
color that contrasts a little bit better
the next trapezoid will go from 2 to 5
next trapezoid goes from 2 to 5 and then
the third trapezoid goes from goes from
5 to 9
the third trapezoid goes from 5 to 9 and
then the fourth trapezoid goes from 9 to
10 goes from 9 to 10 and so if I want to
if I want to approximate the definite
integral part right here before we
divide by 10 I just need to find the
area of these four trapezoids so let's
do that the area of this first trapezoid
is going to be the base which is 2 times
the average height the height on the
left side of this trapezoid is 66 the
height on the right side of this
trapezoid is 60 the average height right
over here is going to be 63 just the
average of 60 and 66 so this area right
over here is this is 126 that's the area
of the green part right over there by
the same logic the
area of this orange part I want to do
that in the orange color the area of
this orange part the base right over
here is three base is three and then the
average height the height over here is
sixty the height over here is 52 this is
there's either eight apart so the
average is going to be far away from
each of is going to be 56 so this is the
area here is going to be 3 times 3 times
56 which is 150 plus 18 150 plus 18 is
168 that's the area of this orange
trapezoid and then the area of this blue
trapezoid the base right over here is 4
and then the average height the height
here is 52 the height here is 44 the
average of 52 and 44 let's see there 10
they are sorry they are 8 apart 8 apart
so then it's just going to be 4 from
each of these so it's 48 so the average
height here is 48 and so 4 times 48 is
160 plus 32 so it's 192 and then finally
this last trapezoid its base is only 1
its base right over here is only 1 and
then it's height is it's 43 at the left
side 43 at the right side so it's
average height is forty three point five
forty three point five so it's forty
three point five times one so that's
just going to be forty three point five
and so if we add up the areas under or
the areas of all these trapezoids we
have a pretty good approximation for the
definite integral I'll just use do the
use the calculator for this part right
over here so we have 126 plus 168 plus
192 plus forty three point five forty
three point five gives us five hundred
and twenty nine point five so this is
equal to five hundred twenty nine point
five and so that's our approximation for
the definite integral part but then we
also have to divide it by ten or we have
to multiply it times 1/10 so we've
evaluated so this part right over here
we got five hundred twenty nine point
five as our
Meishan it's not going to be exact but
using the using the trapezoidal sum the
sum of the areas of these trapezoids and
now we have to multiply it by one-tenth
so let's do that so or we can just
divide by ten which actually we don't
need a calculator for that 52.95 so this
whole thing this whole thing evaluates
to 52.95 and i'll do the next two parts
in the next video